MUZ MOSTOFI: Hi, everyone.
Thank you.
Thanks for coming.
DAN AMINZADE: My
name is Dan Aminzade.
I'm a software
engineer at Google,
and I'm also a
dedicated triathlete.
So on a good week I'll run 50
miles, I'll bike 100 miles,
and I'll maybe write
3,000 lines of code.
So maybe it's no surprise
that I work on the Google Fit
app for Android
Wear, which makes
really extensive use of
the Google Fit platform
APIs that we're going to be
highlighting for you today.
MUZ MOSTOFI: Hi, everyone.
I'm Muz Mostofi.
I'm product manager on
the Google Fit platform.
And I'm a keen,
quantified surfer.
I enjoy weightlifting,
running, yoga,
and occasionally experimenting
with different diets.
Today we're going to
talk about building
rich experiences with the Google
Fit platform and Android Wear.
I'll start out by
talking about why
we created the Fit platform,
what problems we set up
to solve, and then Dan will
go over its APIs and its data
types.
Next, we'll look at some
specific examples of what
you can build with
a Fit platform,
first basic fitness
tracking, and then
a more advanced real
time fitness use case.
Finally, we'll finish up with
some really cool demos coming
soon.
Give me the clicker.
Sorry.
Let's start out by
introducing the Fit platform.
We'll explain why we created
Fit, what problems we set out
to solve, and why we believe
fitness is such a great use
case for wearables.
Before the Google Fit
platform existed life
for a fitness application
developer was not easy.
It was integration Hell.
The first issue was
that of silo data.
Users health and fitness
related sensor data
was siloed across multiple
apps and companion devices.
Second, there was no easy access
and storage of sensor data.
No easy way for developers to
read, interpret, and record
data from health and fitness
related devices, sensors,
and connected companion devices
such as Android devices.
The third problem was
poor interoperability.
There was no simple, standard
way for fitness devices
to interoperate.
So in order to integrate
with the existing app device
ecosystem app
developers would have
to build their own platform
and provide an API.
Some of these would
be poorly implemented,
leading to user frustration.
With the Google Fit platform
we solved that problem
by giving apps one
single set of APIs
to access, record, and
store phone sensor data,
wearable data, and
other app data.
So by using my phone or my
wear device as my fitness hub
I can connect my
fitness wearable
to my favorite nutrition,
and my sleep tracking app
to my favorite meditation app.
We don't just
consolidate data, though.
With user consent we provide
low level sensor recording,
and we perform hard
computations for things
like distance and calories.
Whether it's resting heart rate
from heart rate time stamps,
distances fused from your
height, steps, and GPS,
or calories from heart
rate, the Fit platform
makes it easier for health and
fitness application developers.
And fitness and wearables
truly go hand in hand.
This is for a few reasons.
First, the sensors.
Your app can get access to
all these ways of measuring
fitness activities.
Many watches have a GPS
sensor, a heart rate monitor,
and potentially
even a barometer.
And because the watch
is worn on the wrist
it allows us to
detect activities
that we couldn't do with a phone
being in a pocket or a purse.
So that's the first
reason, sensors.
Second, you can leave the phone.
I love my Nexus 6P, but
running with a device
is a bit cumbersome.
I have to rely on infrequent
audio queue's to find out
my current pace, because I
can't see the screen when it's
in an armband or in my pocket.
Third, faster input.
When you're on the go you
can have quick interactions
with a watch to control music
or activity recording that
would take much
longer if you had
to rely on pulling
out your phone
and opening up the right app.
Now let's talk about what the
Google Fit platform provides
that enables you to build
rich experiences in line
with what we just discussed.
First, let's talk about
the Google Fit app.
So here we have the Google
Fit app on both phone
and on Android Wear.
If you're not
familiar with the app
you can see that it tracks
walking, running, and biking
using the Google
platform's API that
detect activity, associated
steps, calories, and distances.
The app also shows
data from connected
to third party devices
and apps, such as exercise
sessions, weight, heart rate,
nutrition data, and sleep.
Our platform
automatically synchronizes
between your Android phone,
your Android Wear device,
and the web.
The Fit platform exists
in all three of these.
So you can write in data via
our rest APIs on the web,
via our Android
SDKs on the phone,
or the Android SDK on wear.
The platform handles merging and
digi application of this data
intelligently, and we even
support take-out integration
if the user wants to
export their data.
DAN AMINZADE: Thanks, Muz.
So now that you've gotten an
overview of the Google Fit
platform, and maybe
some motivation
for why it might be a good
fit for your fitness app,
let me go into a little more
detail about the different APIs
that it provides.
So basically it breaks
down into four APIs.
First, there's the
SensorsApi, which gives you
access to raw
sensory data streams
from Android devices
and wearable devices
sensors, so things
like heart rate.
Then there's the RecordingApi.
The RecordingApi does automated
storage of fitness data
for you using subscriptions.
You can subscribe to a
data type and Google Fit
will store fitness data for that
data type in the background,
and it'll persist to the
subscription for you.
Next there's the
HistoryApi, which
gives you access to
the fitness history
and lets you perform bulk
operations like reading,
and inserting, and deleting
data from the finished history.
And then finally
there's the SessionsApi.
Sessions are basically
a metadata layer
on top of raw fitness data that
let you store whole fitness
activities.
So a session is a time
interval during which
the user was doing say
a bike ride, or a run,
or weightlifting session.
As far as what you can
record we support really
all the standard data types
for diet, and nutrition, body,
activity, sleep.
We're also adding this
new hydration data type.
I think this is a pretty
exhaustive list of fitness
metrics, but if
there's one that's
not in here that you'd
like to log in your app
you should let us know.
So let's start by talking just
about basic fitness tracking.
You can't measure what you don't
track so tracking measuring is
really, I think, the first
step toward motivating people
towards better fitness.
I actually first started
tracking my workouts
10 years ago, back
in 2006, when I was
training for my first marathon.
And I bought my very
first wrist mounted GPS.
And it was this massive,
ugly, uncomfortable thing,
like the size of a
chinchilla on my wrist.
But it did the job, you know?
I could plug it into
the serial port on my PC
and I could download
XML data of my run.
And back then there weren't
any nice portals or fitness
platforms so to
visualize my runs
I built this website
with Google Maps API 1.0.
And I could put
my runs up there.
And there's something
really thrilling
for a data geek like me to
come back from a workout
and analyze all my stats
on pace, and heart rate,
and elevation.
And I could really track my
progress from week to week,
and workout to workout.
So these days obviously
there are much more elegant
and full featured
alternatives where
I can analyze my workouts,
and share them with friends,
and track my progress
toward fitness goals.
And also I don't have to
wear a big, giant ugly thing
on my wrist.
I can wear these
beautiful time pieces
from TAG Heuer or Michael
Kors, and I can still
track and visualize my
progress right on my wrist
throughout the day
with the watch face.
Now this is actually my favorite
watch face here, the Fit Cat.
Yeah.
Big ups for Fit Cat.
It tries to encourage
you to be more active.
So, basically, if you
haven't seen this before,
the more active that you
are, the more steps you take,
the more active the
cute, little cat becomes.
I love how he's
wearing the I/O badge
and he has the backpack there,
and wearing an Android Wear
watch, also.
So this seems like a
simple concept, right?
The more steps you take, the
more active the cat becomes.
But actually trying to build
something like this on your own
is not easy.
There's a lot of stuff
you have to do if you
want to do it on your own.
You have to build a data
store that tracks steps.
You'd have to turn on
sensors, get permission
from the user to do that.
Then you'd have to
be able to record
step counts in a way that
won't kill the watch battery.
If you get that part working
then when the user first
installs your watch face you
won't-- it will show zero
because you haven't
been recording yet.
And then there's all
these edge cases,
like the user takes
off their watch
and goes for a walk with just
their phone in their pocket,
then you have to write the
logic for merging in that data.
And then even if you
solve all these problems
your step counts
still is probably not
going to be consistent
with other watch faces
in other apps.
So, fortunately, we solved
all of these problems for you
with the Google Fit platform.
We store steps in the background
in a nice, low powered battery
friendly way, and they're ready
to be read anytime you like.
And you can get
consistent step counts
on Android Wear with
just one method call.
So let me just show
you how to do that.
Typically when you want to
connect to the Google Fit
platform you create a
Google API client, right?
And normally you create
an authenticated one
where you specify the account
that you want to read data for.
So here's how I
build the client.
I say that I'm interested in
reading fitness history data
so I add the
fitness history API.
I add scopes for the particular
types of data I want to read.
So in this case activity type,
location, and body sensor data,
like heart rate.
And then next I add an account.
So this is the account I
want to read the data from.
And then finally I
add my callbacks.
And now I have this
authenticated client
that I can use to make queries
to the fitness platform.
But wait, you're saying,
Android Wear watches
don't have accounts.
And this is true.
Android Wear 2.0 will
actually add account support,
but for now we don't
have accounts on watches.
Fortunately, there
is a solution.
Now you could sync account
information from the phone,
but this would
require a watch face
to have a companion
phone app, which
is a lot more complicated.
So here's an easier way to
do it without a phone app.
You can create a
no account client.
So you create a
Google API client.
As before, we're going
to add the History API.
And now we just call
set default account.
We don't specify an account.
Finish building it, and
now we have a new account
client that we can still
use to query step counts.
And the way you do that is with
the read daily totals method.
So you're going to
call the History
APIs read daily total method.
And this is basically going
to give you a simple way
to get step counts
for watch face that's
going to be consistent with
other apps and other watch
faces.
You can set a callback so
that when the result returns
you can process it.
So here in the on result I'm
basically just extracting out
the step count, putting it
into a steps total variable,
and there you go.
It's a pretty simple
way to track steps
with your watch face.
And it's not just steps that
you can get from the Google Fit
platform.
You can also read
and write other data,
like calories consumed.
So here's an example of how the
Lifesum app displays that data.
Here I'm looking at
the amount of calories
I have left in my
budget for the day, 911.
So I guess I could
eat like two avocados
and drink two glasses
of wine tonight.
Android Wear 2.0 is
going to have a new way
to show data on watch
faces using complications.
Maybe you've seen some of
this earlier in the keynote.
But, basically, on
the right there's
a watch face that has
three complications.
And the watch face
lets you select
which complications you
want, and then any app
can provide data for
those complications.
So here's an example where
Lifesum is exporting data
on calories burned
as a complication
so that the ranger
watch-- it's switch is
on the right-- can display
it in one of those three user
configurable slots.
And if you want more information
on building complications
in Android Wear 2.0 highly
recommend you check out
the talk-- there's a dedicated
talk at 4pm on this topic.
MUZ MOSTOFI: Another challenge
that fitness developers
face is how to perform
difficult computations.
For example, to derive
distance traveled
from multiple sensory
inputs the user's height,
stride length, GPS data,
activity type, active time,
and step counts all have to be
fused in together, potentially
across multiple sensory inputs.
The Fit platform makes this
easy for third party developers
through its advanced
transformations
for both distance and calories.
The basis app takes
advantage of this.
Instead of computing
distance themselves
they write in steps
and activity data
into the Google Fit
platform, and read back
our computed values
for distance.
DAN AMINZADE: Cool.
So let's take a look at how we
might do something like this
with the Google Fit platform.
So there is really-- there
are two ways of writing data
to the platform.
You can use the recording
API to do live recording.
And then you can use the History
API to insert activity history.
So let's actually start by
looking at live recording.
All we have to do
to start recording
is to subscribe to the
data type we care about.
So here I'm calling
subscribe and I'm
saying I'm interested
in activity samples--
activity type.
And then-- I actually, at that
point, I am essentially done.
Google Fit will start
storing that data
that I care about
in the background.
So I don't need my own database
or my back-end to store it,
there's no listener needed here.
Basically, the
Google Fit platform
is going to start recording
data and syncing it
to the cloud in the background.
And when I want it
later I can just
read it with the History API.
So once I subscribe I'm done.
All I really need
to do is just check
the status code
in the on result.
And that's just to make
sure that the subscription
succeeded.
Now let's look at another
way of getting data
into the Fitness history.
Suppose I've gotten my data
from some external source,
like another device.
So in the example of basis they
wanted to write in some steps
that they had gotten
from another device.
So first you create
this data source object,
and you specify the type of
data you want to write here.
I'm saying I want to
write raw step count data.
And then you create a data
set from the data source.
And you add one or more
data points to the data set.
Each of these points has
a start and an end time.
So here I'm adding 950 steps
with a start and an end time.
And then, finally, you
just call insert data
to put the data into the fitness
history, and that's about it.
All you really have to do after
that is just basically verify
that the operation succeeded
before you start querying
the data with the history API.
And one nice thing is that
the Fit platform will actually
validate the data
points that you insert.
So, for example, if I put
in an invalid time range,
or I put in a really
unrealistically high calorie
burn, or cadence, or
something like that,
I'll get an error back in the
client instead of the user
history getting all messed up.
So here's how this actually
looks in the basis app.
They put in steps,
and then you can
see they are able to derive from
that-- or through the Google
Fit platform they get this
accurate distance traveled.
MUZ MOSTOFI: We've been
working hard over the past year
to improve the quality
of these transformations.
The first area with
which we've improved them
is relation to distance.
Distance computed from
steps now has been improved
with stride length calibration.
From actively trucked
walks and runs
to improve the quality
of passively tacked
walks and runs.
Secondly, for
calories, we will soon
be leveraging gender,
age, and heart rate
as part of our computations
to improve the accuracy.
Thirdly, for merging.
Previously leaving
your phone at your desk
and going for a walk with
your Android Wear device
would result in your step
counts dipping back down
and then rubber banding back up.
That will no longer be the case
through bi-directional syncing.
We've also made
merging of our GPS data
better by prioritizing the
highest fidelity GPS sources.
Finally, with regards
to activities,
this is our most complex task,
to infer the activity being
performed by analyzing multiple
sensory inputs in real time.
It's really important,
as users get frustrated
when their fitness data has
false positive and false
negative activity.
And they don't get their
proper calories and step counts
as a result.
Fortunately, Google
is good and trusted
at collecting and
understanding complex data
through our advanced machine
learning capabilities.
We've added dynamic
sampling of sensor inputs
to improve quality, and
have made improvements
to our algorithms by fusing
steps, position, speed,
and user corrections together.
The result of this hard
work over the past year
is a reduction in our
biking precision error rates
from 11% error in early 2015
down to 4% error as of now.
And these changes will
be rolling out now.
Finally, we've added
stride length calibration
to the Fit platform.
Which we hope will greatly
benefit non-GPS Android Wear
devices.
So now if a user goes
running initially
with their phone and
their watch, which
has-- the phone which
has GPS and the watch,
which doesn't, the two will
calibrate together and generate
a stride model and then they'll
get accurate distance and pace
estimates running
without their phone,
just with their non-GPS
Android Wear device.
Now that we've looked at some
basic fitness tracking examples
I want to talk about
our push this year
into real time fitness tracking.
But why is real
time so important
when building a motivating
fitness experience?
Well, when I look at
fitness apps out there--
and I look at a lot of
I see that they
adopt this framework.
They start with the
goal of the user.
For example, I'd like
to lose 10 pounds.
I'd like to sleep better, or I'd
like to finish a half marathon.
They recognize that in order
to accomplish this goal
they need to encourage a
pattern of motivating actions
so that the user achieves
the result that they desire.
Let's drill into these
motivating actions.
There are three pillars of
wellness, exercise, nutrition,
and recovery.
Recovery we mean to mean
sleep and meditation.
But these pillars do not
operate independently.
And behavior in one needs to
be balanced against the other.
By getting a holistic
view of what's
going on in each of
these areas your app
can more intelligently
and insightfully
present suggestions and nudges
based on a changing fitness
context in real time.
For example, a sleep
app might observe
that you sleep better
when you exercise,
or when you eat less
sugar in the evening.
An exercise app may
suggest exercise
based on your logged
nutrition data
so that you meet your
weight loss goals.
Note, that in all these cases
timeliness is important.
The best time to coach
and motivate a user
is immediately in
response to an action
that they have taken in
relation to their fitness.
So good apps have an inbuilt
awareness of the user's
overall fitness context.
One of our partners,
Lifesum makes
heavy use of these principles
in their application.
And they integrate deeply
with the fit platform APIs,
and as a result they've seen
double the retention rate
for their users connected
to Fit versus their users
who aren't connected to Fit.
And who are the APIs
that we've added
to let you respond in real
time to a changing fitness
context for your user?
First, there's Real Time
Data Update Notifications.
It allows you to be
notified for certain data
types in the fitness
store when they change.
The second is Real Time
Session Notifications.
It's actually been in
the platform for awhile,
but we'd like to
talk about it today.
It allows you to be notified
that the user has started
or finished a workout tracked
in the third party application.
And, finally, there's Real
Time Activity Recognition.
Coming soon to
Android Wear devices
to detect the onset of activity
to launch into your activity--
active tracking experience.
Let's dive into the first
API, Real Time Data Update
Notifications.
This allows us to build
the following experience.
Say I just had an
impromptu pizza
and I've exceeded my calorie
intake goal for the day.
I can get a notification from
my weight scale app telling me,
listen, more exercise is
needed to keep you on track
to meet your weight loss goal.
DAN AMINZADE: I do admit I
have a weakness for pizza
and that one looked
pretty delicious.
So let's see how we could build
something like that example
that Muz just described.
What we want to do is
subscribe to updates
to the nutrition data type.
So first thing we do is
create a PendingIntent.
This is typically a
PendingIntent for an Intents
service that's going
to call into your app
whenever an update to one
of these data types occurs.
What you then do is you
create a DataUpdateListen
erRegistrationRequest, which
is a lot of camel case,
but it is a pretty
descriptive name.
And we're going to pass
in the type of data
that we'd like to
subscribe to updates for.
So in this case nutrition,
we're interested in meals
that are being logged.
And then we pass on that
PendingIntent we created.
And then, finally,
we just call this
RegisterDataUpdateListenerMethod
and we pass
in our client and our request.
And then, voila,
we'll get an update
with the next logged meal.
And, of course, you can
register for updates
to all different
kinds of data types.
For example, if I want
to be notified every time
the user steps on their
scale and logs a new weight
I can do that with type weight.
And here are actually
all of the data types
that support real time updates.
Pretty much anything that
isn't updated super frequently.
MUZ MOSTOFI: The second API,
Real Time Session Update
Notifications,
allows, for example,
a nutrition app to be
notified that a user just
finished a workout session.
So say you just finished
a weightlifting session,
your nutrition app can
tell you, it's time
to get a high protein meal in
to maximize your muscle growth.
Or, say a hydration logging app.
It can suggest
rehydrating immediately
after finishing a 21
minute run outdoors.
DAN AMINZADE: Yeah, It's been
so hot here I don't think--
I think we can all use
hydration reminders even
if we haven't been running,
just walking around outside.
So let's build that one.
Similar API to the
one that we just
looked at with the
HistoryApi, but here we're
going to use the
SessionsApi because we're
interested in
registering for updates
when a session starts or ends.
So again we create
a PendingIntent
that we'd like to fire when
a new session begins or ends.
And then we call this
register for sessions method
in the Sessions API.
And now whenever the user
starts or ends a workout
the PendingIntent
will fire and intent
will be delivered to our app.
And if you want to get more
information on that session
you can actually extract
it from out of the Intent.
So here I'm pulling out the
start and end time, and then
also the type of workout.
So whether it was a
run, or a bike ride,
or a weightlifting
session, and I
can put that into the
notification like the one
that Muz just showed.
One exciting new
development that's
coming to the Google
Fit platform this year
is that we're actually
going to allow your app
to register not only for
these explicit sessions
that the user initiate, but
also for implicit sessions.
These are ones that
are automatically
detected by our platform.
So what it means is that your
app can respond in real time
to user's fitness activity.
So if I just lace
up my shoes and I
start running my
favorite run tracking app
can just start up
automatically on my watch.
So I'm going to try to show
you a demo of how that works.
I'm not really properly
dressed for running,
but I'm going to do a
little run around here.
OK, I just felt my
wrist vibrate which
means that Strava should
have started up on my watch.
So let's go over
here and take a look.
And there we go.
So you can see that Strava
is now recording my run.
And I'll post that
on Strava later
so I hope you can
give me some kudos.
Here you go, Muz.
MUZ MOSTOFI: Awesome.
So we got a couple
of really exciting--
well three, actually,
really exciting new features
going on Android Wear
towards the end of the year.
We've added a Beat to Beat API
in Android M. What this allows
you to do is get the heart
rate time stamps in addition
to the BPMs.
And compute heart
rate variability,
which is a proxy for
stress levels for the user.
Second, we're
adding a profileApi.
This allows you
to easily onboard
you new users by reading age,
gender, height, and weight
from the Fit platform.
And, finally,
GoalsApi allowing you
not only to show, for
example, just the step count,
but also the progress
against that step goal.
But also active time,
distance, and calorie
goals as well from Google Fit.
There's another exciting
feature that some of guys
might have seen at
the sandbox already.
so when I go to the gym I
notice that a lot of people
are still using
an old school pen
and paper to log their exercise,
their reps, their weight.
Seems a bit crazy in 2016.
Well Google fit on Android
Wear did count reps for you
for three specific exercises,
push-ups, sit-ups, and squats,
but only if you told the app
in advance what you were doing.
This is still somewhat
limited and cumbersome.
Now we've got something better.
So I'm going to show you a demo.
DAN AMINZADE: Oh, come on, Muz.
MUZ MOSTOFI: Oh, all right.
All right.
OK.
Maybe.
Oh.
DAN AMINZADE: Give me a break.
MUZ MOSTOFI: OK, so I'm going
to the Google Fit strength
training section.
And I haven't told it the
exercise I'm about to do.
DAN AMINZADE: Come on.
Woo!
He's working hard for you guys.
MUZ MOSTOFI: As you can see it
detected bicep curls with 100%.
[APPLAUSE]
And counted the reps.
It was 15 pounds so
I'll just log that.
Let's do another exercise,
one which involves the legs.
Note that I can take some
time just kind of setting up.
DAN AMINZADE: Very good form.
MUZ MOSTOFI: That's not.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
I'll put these down.
And you can see it got deadlift.
DAN AMINZADE: Yay.
[APPLAUSE]
MUZ MOSTOFI: If a rep is missed,
or an exercise isn't correct,
for whatever reason, we
will learn from that mistake
and become trained to the
user's exercise motion.
We aim to seamlessly track a
whole workout with minimal user
input.
We're planning an API
towards the end of this year
and we're looking for partners.
DAN AMINZADE: All right.
So that's our overview of
the Google Fit platform.
Before we wrap up we just want
to thank all of our partners
who are already using the
Google Fit platform to inspire
and motivate people
around the world
to lead more healthy
and active lifestyle.
You know, at the end of the
day this talk isn't really
about pending intents
and broadcast receivers,
it's about improving lives
and extending life spans.
And so we really
hope that you'll
be inspired to get
out there and build
the next generation of awesome,
amazing fitness experiences
on Android.
So thanks so much for
your time and attention.
Feel free to contact
us with any questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]